- Did you have bad dreams about driving?
I heard that you had some bad dreams.
- Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What were your dreams, you just wrecked?
- My dreams were always
that I was in a car.
The car was going really,
really fast, but I didn't know,
I didn't know what the PRNDL was.
I didn't know what the
buttons were on the car.
So I couldn't, I didn't know how
to work the car.
- What did you just say?
- The PRNDL, you know, from
Suite Life to Zack and Cody.
(audience cheering)
- The PRNDL?
- Where Mr. Mosby's like
teaching London Tipton
how to drive and he's like
- You know what?
- the PRNDL.
(audience laughing)
- We just discovered our
age difference just now.
(audience laughing)
I was like, wait, what
the hell's the PRNDL?
- What were your shows that you watched?
- Saved by the Bell, man.
- Okay.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah, I was like, that was,
I was young for Saved by the Bell,
but yes.
- Yeah, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Mine was Suit Life of Zack and Cody,
like That's So Raven anyway, so.
(audience cheering)
- Okay, I know That's So Raven.
I know that one.
- Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- So anyway, so he calls
it the PRNDL and then,
no she calls it the PRNDL, right?
- Yeah.
- And then he's like,
oh, would you like to listen to AM or FM,
like AM or FM.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He makes fun of her,
but anyway, so I had
this recurring nightmare
that I was driving really fast,
I didn't know how to break.
I didn't know how to do anything.
And so I was like.
- Loss of control.
- There's only one way to stop this.
- Yeah.
- Learning how to drive.
- You gotta learn
how to drive.
- Yeah, totally.
- Yeah.
- Loss of control, that's
probably what that means, right?
- I always feel like, yeah.
I feel like all of my dreams
- Mean something.
- mean loss of control.
- What does it mean when you like
lose your teeth in a dream?
- I think that isn't that like your,
isn't that also loss of control?
Like you feel like you,
you have no control
over you life.
- I guess I always feel
out of control.
- I think everything
is loss of control.
- Yeah.
- This is what I,
this is my dream book.
- Yeah, right.